good morning president Levin Provost
olive a Dean Pollard Chaplin Kugler
masters Dean's and honored guests and
welcome women and men of the class of
2014
welcome
welcome
welcome to Yale University and welcome
to Yale College I am we are all so
excited to have you here we've been
thinking about you since April 1 when
Dean Grendel of Admissions told us your
names then we met more of you during
Bulldog days and we met more of you this
week in pre orientation programs and
masters and Dean's watched with joy as
did parents as upperclassmen ran your
boxes upstairs but at last 2014 you are
here welcome inside the gates onto the
playing fields into the classrooms and
the residential colleges welcome to the
spaces and places you will soon call
home and welcome to all the families and
friends who brought you to this day
you've come from Ghana and new haven
from Canada in China from Georgia and
Georgia from
from Berkeley Butte and Brooklyn thanks
for having helped 1344 of the world's
smartest and most interesting young
women and men find their way to today we
are going to have exceptional encounters
with them over the next year's in the
classrooms dining halls intramural
fields extracurricular activities and
let me add that we plan to have plenty
of fun along the way
but 2014 back to you you've just arrived
and surely you have noticed our motto
looks at Veritas light and truth and it
appears on everything in Latin and
Hebrew thanks to the design of Woolsey
Hall we've got huge windows that let in
plenty of light and I hope ere today too
so let's spend our time this morning
talking about truth a very difficult
concept to grasp and one you might think
belongs in a philosophy class but truth
is a subject we take on and tackle every
day in the honesty of self presentation
and of representation when we discuss
truth were often arguing about what we
think is right and why I'm an art
historian of Mesoamerica roughly ancient
Mexico and Central America and I've been
giving some thought to the notion of
truth of representation among the Aztecs
and Maya if we might ever have thought
mindlessly that certain images and
representations were true certainly the
current technology from Photoshop to
Pixar quickly disabuse 'iz us of that
notion but the notion of truth of
representation has always been a
question in the Western tradition
Plato first set it up this way the gods
create a bed the carpenter makes a bed
and at the third remove is the artist
who paints the bed the problem with the
painters effort unlike that of the gods
or the carpenter says Plato the painters
picture isn't real whatever it is it's
not the thing that it represents just to
put it another way if an artist makes a
pumpkin out of stone or clay isn't a
pumpkin you can make into a pie and so
the history of Western thought begins
with this anxiety about the real and the
invented the tension between factor of
the useful and production of the
imaginary my point here is not to review
this claim but if the representation if
the representation is about the
engagement with nature an engagement
with things divinely made as Plato would
say then there is much to say about
things made in the ancient new world
when we look at an ancient something
that represents something else and we
can see at our remove of hundreds or
thousands of years we know what that
something is then we know that the
ancient artist has successfully mastered
the replication of a form of a thing of
an idea of a word and if this
representation is a sort of truth then
it has to be a kind of fiction you can't
make a pie out of a stone pumpkin so
let's start with an example you have in
front of you an image I doubt you've
seen before well maybe one or two of you
have I learned that there are two of you
from New Orleans a few more from
Louisiana this object is a prized object
prized work at the New Orleans Museum of
Art but go ahead turn it back into the
cylinder Cup that it is you can and I
have cut mine and I bring Exhibit A so
it's about half life-size the one you
have in your hand and you'll see that
there's one seated figure two aside each
one with a monkey body a human body and
a monkey face but in human clothing and
each is madly writing in a book found by
Jaguar Pelt and held in the left hand
the right hand is bound up and tied to
hold some kind of a writing tool now
look closely these are supernatural
scribes the deified patrons
of heart writing music and dance of
invention and creativity students of the
ancient Maya know them to be the monkey
scribes non identical twins and there
are more than a few of you here today
who knows something about being a twin
or more well in Maya art it is monkey
scribes who teach novices to paint to
write words and to inscribe numbers they
want us to be in all of them and so they
have managed their own representations
and made themselves quite horrifying but
why have I Glee scribes especially if
they control the imagery why would the
scribes not improve their headshots by
making themselves more beautiful the
most beautiful and best of humans why
instead should scribes be monkeys can
monkeys draw can they do more than
imitate is it just monkey see monkey do
can they reveal truth after the Spanish
invasion of Mexico in 1519 no group was
more troubling to the Spanish than the
scribes and priests of native traditions
for the Spanish what Aztec Maya and
others held to be true were in their
eyes lies and deceptions of the devil
even as the advaita invaders sought
advice from the sons of these same
spiritual leaders in order to try to
interpret this brave new world they
subscribed to the view that the most
vulnerable and dangerous individuals in
any regime are the learned ones the
intellectuals you might be reminded here
of the flight from their country of the
iraqi professor and professor yet
neither exclusively Sunni nor Shiite yet
all feared if not hated for their very
learning their ability to read lessons
from the past and to solve problems
based on research and experiment but
it's easy to bash learning from so many
directions
nothing grieves scholars and students in
my field of study more than when the
late Wisconsin Senator William Proxmire
held up a new dip
canary from the Smithsonian one of the
most important 20th century works of
linguistic scholarship on the ancient
Maya and assigned it his Golden Fleece
award even the unpolitical scribe can be
made to seem political is it possible
not to seem to be taking sides Oh such
so much better to pretend to be a monkey
to keep one's head down to retreat to
the idea that art and writing are simply
imitation except plato's damnation and
admit it's better to be a carpenter plum
what it is that Shakespeare means and
Henry the sixth part - when a base and
murderous character shouts first thing
we do let's kill all the lawyers a
lawyer of course was and is a scribe the
individual who sorted out truth or at
least a truth in text that our Maya
scribes understood all the danger of
learnin Asst that all the studies since
childhood
the hunched posture earned in days of
painting and writing that art and
writing whether fiction or fact could
expose one to death and torture and
exile and that both imitation and
innovation pose their dangers all this
the Maya scribe understood in seeing the
monkey as the artist patron avoiding
seeming to be the genesis of ideas
whether verbal or visual while
nevertheless championing championing
innovation and finding that innovation
could be rewarded must have been one of
the artists most artful performances
these artists Venice now must have
wrestled with the dissonance between the
act of making and its outcomes Maya
artists like their counterparts around
the world all trained the artist who's
painted surface lies in your lap worked
with in a very carefully limited
tradition in the tropical rainforest
where this was made almost nothing
fives no rough drafts no training
manuals no guide to the opening days but
fortunately fired play is one of the
most durable materials that humans have
ever invented the finished works of the
ancient Maya revealed constant practice
and careful work flights of genius and
self-reflection on what it is that
practice ingenious can bring together
what is also clear is that the making
requires exquisite craft that is to say
that training repetitious repetition
practice analysis of raw material all
these undergird the outcome when you
write your name on a paper or a painting
or a drawing what do you mean is it
yours
learning and writing have always been
hard for Maya scribes and for Yale
college students the lifting of words
from famous writing writers or from
Wikipedia from drafts posed online it's
now so easy as it is to take ideas from
others but it's also never been easier
to retrace your steps and track down a
citation that you neglected to note in
the first event the New York Times has
been printing articles this summer about
the problems of plagiarism and academic
honesty for the current generation of
high school and college students that's
you your work will not exist and if it
does not draw from others and learn how
to enter the conversation a critical
part of what we do in our academic work
here at Yale is to make that clear in
this sense all our Labor's are
collaboration we cannot paint the bed
that Plato spoke of unless a carpenter's
first made one the most successful
fiction of an artist has a
backstory in crafts whether you are
writing the report of a lab experiment
or an essay in developmental psych you
will retrace some familiar steps no
matter how far we think we see it is
only because we stand on the shoulders
of others acknowledging those shoulders
and that work this is the coin of the
realm in our University
if you sing if you act you develop a
voice but it will always be shaped by
the composer or the author or by those
who have performed those notes or spoken
those lines before you did as you write
as you learn you will find your own
voice and it will be truly yours but you
will never find it alone others will be
there silently shaping that new truth so
let's take a look at this little Maya
pot again you see I've put it back
together following his ancestors his
mentors his teachers the artist has
developed a new way to draw a cursive
sole of the monkey scribes foot and a
fresh way of representing the flat hands
that's underneath the book drawing quick
cursive lines he paints with clay slip
little more than charcoal suspended in
clay slurry for there was no glaze and
he and his shop seemed to have worked
with a particular set of Potter's who
built such vessels of coils of clay for
there was no wheel in the ancient new
world the technology of their work was
so limited yet the results so stunning
the ancient Maya knew how to take one
material clay and turn it into something
else like assembling poetry out of words
and syllables or building a structure
out of rock that has yet to be quarried
and oh I should mention what was the
function of this little pot this example
doesn't happen to include a textual tag
that might named function painter or
patron but others commonly do and I'll
just
there's one at the Yale art gallery that
has exactly that kind of text and these
written tags as well as archaeologically
attested traces tell us that this is a
pot for frothy zesty and bitter
chocolate drink the party drink of
preference for the ancient Maya so I now
lift this little pot of chocolate to you
class of 2014 and hope that its richness
and spiciness will envelop you in your
quest for truth at Yale 2014
you
you
good morning I am delighted to join with
Dean Miller and welcoming you the class
of 2014 to Yale College I want to
welcome also the relatives and friends
who have accompanied you here and
especially your parents as a father of
four college graduates I know how proud
your parents are of your chilled you
parents are of your children's
achievement how hopeful you are for
their future and how many concerns both
large and small that you have at this
moment so let me try to reassure you
your children are going to love it here
and you are going to enjoy your
association with Yale to whether you're
a whether you are a returning graduate
or one of the vast majority of parents
who never set foot in New Haven until
your children started to think about
where to go to college you may take some
comfort in learning that surveys have
shown that Yale parents are the most
satisfied in the Ivy League so welcome
to the Yale family we're very pleased to
have your children with us and we will
do our best to provide them with
abundant opportunities to learn and to
thrive in the four years ahead and to
you class of 2014 I make the same pledge
for you these next four years will be a
time of opportunity unlike any other
here you are surrounded by astonishing
resources fascinating fellow students
from all over the world a learned and
caring faculty intimate residential
college communities a magnificent
library to extraordinary art museums an
outstanding Museum of Natural History
superb athletic facilities and student
organizations covering every conceivable
interest
the performing arts politics community
service among others you will have
complete freedom so explore to learn
about new subjects to meet new people to
pursue new passions I want to encourage
you in every way that I can to make use
to make the most of this rare and unique
opportunity let's start with your
academic program most likely you will be
just overwhelmed by the more than 2,000
courses that are available to you in
fact you will inevitably miss out on 98%
of them but let me urge you nonetheless
to sample widely each of the scholarly
disciplines provides a different
perspective on the human experience each
allows you a different window on the
accumulated knowledge of nature and
culture and each quite literally allows
you to see the world differently if I
could offer only one piece of advice
about selecting courses it would be this
stretch yourselves don't assume that you
know in advance what fields interest you
the most take some courses in fields
that are entirely outside the range of
your past experience you will not only
emerge as a more broadly educated person
but you will also stand a better chance
of discovering an unsuspected passion
that helps to shape the future course of
your life by studying philosophy for
example you will learn to reason more
rigorously and to discern more readily
what constitutes a logically consistent
argument and what does not and you'll
study texts that wrestle directly with
the deepest questions of how one should
live your professors of literature music
and our history will teach you to read
listen and see closely and help you to
develop a keener appreciation for the
artistry that makes literature
and visual art sublime representations
of human emotions values and ideas
whether you major in these subjects or
not your appreciation of what is true
and beautiful will be enriched forever
your professors of history will teach
you to appreciate the challenging art of
reconstructing the past and to
understand how meaning can be extracted
from experience this may help you gain
perspective on your own experience years
ago when I taught introductory economics
in Yale College
I always began by telling the students
that the course would change their lives
why because economics will open you to
an entirely new and different way of
understanding how the world works
economics will not prescribe for you how
society should be organized of the
extent to which individual freedom
should be subordinated to collective
ends or how the fruits of human labor
should be distributed but understanding
the logic of markets will give you a new
way of thinking about these perpetually
important questions and in similar
fashion each of the other social
sciences psychology political science
anthropology sociology and linguistics
will give you a different perspective on
human experience in society now some of
you may already have a passion for
science or mathematics and you may have
set your sights for a major in science
math or engineering and there is so much
in these pursuits to excite the
imagination that I hardly need to
elaborate in science we're in the midst
of discovering the causes of human
disease the mechanisms of evolution and
the origins of the universe in
engineering we have unprecedented
opportunities to develop new materials
new medical devices and new sources of
energy one of the virtues of studying
science and engineering at a place like
Yale is that you can practice science
and engineering while you study it you
can work in research laboratories
belongs
your professors on problems at the very
frontier of knowledge so with respect to
science I have two messages that are
mirror images first if you are someone
with an early or emerging passion for
science take the time to study other
subjects as well even if you pursue
science or engineering as a career
broadening your education in the other
liberal arts will enrich your lives both
both enrich your lives and increase and
improve your science and second if you
are one of those who does not think
yourself a science type don't just
fulfill the science requirement give
science a serious try during the past
decade we've developed a number of
problem oriented science courses without
free requisites they are meant to give
you a rigorous exposure to science
without the comprehensiveness of survey
courses that are designed for those
already committed to a major or a
pre-medical curriculum so try one or two
of these courses early on and you may be
surprised by your newfound enthusiasm
and to complete this mini tour of the
curriculum we will not let you forget
about writing math and foreign languages
some attention to these skills is
required but there are many ways to
satisfy the requirements and again I
would urge you to stretch yourselves try
something different an expository or
creative writing class or statistics
instead of more calculus or a new
language even as you pursue further
study of one you already know now my
suggestion that you stretch yourself is
not limited to the classroom it applies
to both the friends and the
extracurricular activities you choose as
well if the friends you make here are
exclusively those who come from
backgrounds just like your own and went
to high schools just like your own you
will have forfeited half the value of a
alien
education you come from 50 states and
from 58 countries from a wide range of
social of racial religious and
socioeconomic backgrounds each of your
residential colleges reflects within
itself that rich diversity so seek out
friends with different histories and
different interests you'll find that you
learn the most from the people the least
like you no doubt you'll participate in
one or more of the 300 student
organizations on campus as well as
varsity club and intramural athletic
teams you may find your consuming
passion the passion that shapes your
life after Yale in one of these pursuits
I can think of scores of journalists
public servants teachers startup
entrepreneurs performers and filmmakers
whose career choices were shaped by
their extracurricular activities here at
Yale and again my advice is move beyond
the familiar try at least one
extracurricular activity that's
brand-new to you and by all means do not
spend all your time with your varsity
teammates or your fellow single group
members or your the others who write for
the Yale Daily News make the most of the
extraordinary variety of people and
opportunities that are available to you
here so far my advice to use is focused
entirely on how you might get the most
out of your Yale education you might be
wondering am I here just to exploit all
of Yale's treasures for myself alone
well the answer is no we have confidence
based on the evidence of history and
knowledge of the culture of this place
that your journey towards self-discovery
your progress toward finding your
passion will yield more than self
gratification and personal advancement
we believe that because you are
intelligent
reflective members of a community of
scholars that you will come to recognize
that with the abundant opportunities for
self enrichment that Yale provides there
also come responsibilities and what are
these responsibilities they begin with
responsibility for the well-being of the
institution that you are joining today
let me remind you that even for those of
you whose parents are paying the full
tuition room and board charges more than
half the total cost of your Yale
education is supported by gifts of those
who came before you more than half of
you hold scholarships and most of our
buildings athletic facilities museum and
library collections trace to gifts from
graduates of Yale College your
responsibilities also include good
citizenship in its many varieties at
Yale's founding this took the form of
supporting the young New Haven colony
and the Congregational Church today
while volunteer service to local
community organizations both secular and
religious remains a distinguishing
characteristic of Yale graduates our
horizons have broadened some of you will
undoubtedly carry on Yale's great
tradition of producing national leaders
and for all of you who spend most of
your adult lives in the United States
there is an emerging burden of
citizenship that will be yours to bear
and that is the powerfully important
burden of helping to raise the level of
public discourse and making our
democracy work one has only to compare
the rhetoric of today's leaders with the
speeches of Abraham Lincoln given 150
years ago or with the transcripts of the
kennedy-nixon debates of 50 years ago to
see how oversimplified ideology and
appeal to narrow interest groups have
triumphed over intelligence and
moderation
in public discussion by insisting as
citizens on serious discussion instead
of slogans that mask narrow partisan
interests you can help make our
democracy more effective today because
the world is so highly interconnected
and interdependent you will have the
added responsibility of acting as global
citizens your generation more than any
that has gone before will need deep
knowledge of an intimate engagement with
cultures and societies very different
from your own those of you who come from
abroad will of course experience
immersion in another culture right here
in New Haven the rest of you may do so
by taking advantage of one or more of
our many programs of work or study
abroad such an experience will stretch
you in just the way I'm recommending
more generally it will force you to see
yourself from a different perspective
and to see others free from
preconceptions since so many of the
issues confronting us from poverty and
disease to the proliferation of nuclear
weapons require cooperative
international solutions a cross-cultural
perspective is invaluable even before
you travel overseas you might start by
preparing yourself yourselves for global
citizenship by sampling some of the
courses in international studies offered
by our recently established Jackson
Institute such as the new
multidisciplinary gateway course on
global affairs now in addition to these
burdens of local national and
international citizenship that I've
mentioned your generation will need to
rise as well to the challenge of
planetary stewardship without a radical
reduction in emissions of greenhouse
gases too
during your lifetimes much of humanity
will suffer dislocation and famine on an
unprecedented scale we have both the
current means to slow down the
accumulation of atmospheric carbon and
the imagination to develop the
technologies needed to prevent
catastrophe we seem to lack only the
conviction and collective will you of
course will need to scrutinize the
evidence for yourselves with all the
critical intelligence that you can
muster but if you do I'm confident that
you will assume this last responsibility
as well and you'll have the opportunity
to practice planetary stewardship right
here at Yale as we try to model what it
means to become a sustainable campus
women and men of the class of 2014 we
take the greatest pleasure in welcoming
you here to Yale College and we delight
in the anticipation of the opportunities
that you will seize and that there and
the responsibilities that you will come
to shoulder as citizens of your
communities the nation the world and the
planet welcome to Yale